citizens of the reject Nation it is time
to go back to the dcau we think with
Batman bad blood does it have vampires
does it have blood because there's a
little sharpness to that M Batman that
could be a Batman what do you think John
I'm not even seeing it because I haven't
seen it I think we got bad blood and we
used to have mad love and now we're
gonna find out what caused this for the
bat family is there a bad romance afoot
there's a bad romance Love is a
Battlefield very excited the last thing
we watched was Turtles which we both
loved maybe the most can potential
vampires keep up let's find out please
like subscribe hit that notification
Bell leave a comment let us know which
of these is your favorite and if this
has vampires because by them well now
the patrons you get this whole thing the
start to finish end to end and that is a
unique experience because it features
our watching faces
which you can only get there and frankly
that is well worth the experience we
love those sexy Rejects and the patreon
also I want to say all these have been
fueled by G fuel sometimes off camera
prepping sometimes on camera as of now I
know Greg loves them but I haven't told
you guys how much I love them I love it
like without caffeine I'm nothing but
with the wrong caffeine I crash and I'm
worse than nothing can you feel oh crash
just a good time and it's like zesty
energy I'm like this is my Lazarus
picture
like it's necessary without the
transformation aspect well it's like a
it's like a mental transformation but I
don't have to get all gooey that's what
I'm saying and I do believe there is a
discount code in the box below the
description right discount code it's a
reject Nation yeah save yourself 20
percent of Select tubs my friend that's
a fifth dollar back every five bucks
that's four dollars back every 20 bucks
that's 20 every 100 so you save some
money you save up you be Batman invest
in some stocks
different animation intro every time
Nightwings in the city that's true uh I
do like that the C kind of tells us like
a foundational character black mask mob
was kidnapped at gunpoint by masked
assailants earlier today good diction
Saul was a victim of the recent Turf War
composed of high-tech criminals known to
have cost paths with Batman I gave good
diction
[Music]
big diction
Ary
oh interesting design on him oh Firefly
sure
that's when someone lies there's not
almost Rey Winstone in every one of
these yep and yet it's never Ray
Winstone what's he doing being a black
widow
[Music]
oh boy right out of his boots Batman
doesn't use guns
Batman doesn't cheer that Zack style oh
dang dude
cool cool
[Music]
let's go Ruby Rose ain't messing around
oh nice
I like how our five style is completely
different but like brutal in her own way
yeah the inertia is crazy
nice shot that's no way to treat a lady
Jason O'Mara's back
[Applause]
geez dressing like a bat doesn't make
you a hero it just makes you a Target
and using a gun makes you just like them
it's the two of the enemy Babs you fool
that's bad woman not bad girl stupid
stupid
dang pack drones
I mean they're pretty effective against
the machinery
[Music]
dang
yellow jacket
Corey's still just showing up everything
everywhere Modoc oh I get it acronym
I've waited so
and not at all
another riddle guy
[Music]
did well
just destroy the whole thing for good
measure wowza
[Music]
I don't think it's vampires nope I'm
gonna go I don't feel like it's the
literal Bad Blood of like you know
relationships like there's a there's a
history it's thematic Bad Blood yeah not
literal not literal Bad Blood all blood
you see on screen is good blood yeah
[Music]
it's not like he punches a Time clock
but I can assure you that the gun news
52 new 52.
I like that coat
blood
Nightwing Centric At Last I almost
forgotten what you feel like
what's all that noise
that's my night job I think I see an
opening
[Music]
oh yeah
got a family emergency Nightwing out oh
she knows he's nice oh it's like driving
well your trip to the rainforest seems
ill-timed Mr Wayne and I can do whatever
the bloody hell I want to frankly I
think we're done here bring them to
Lucius he's more than capable of
handling things while I'm gone
deep fake Alfred wisdom how long has he
been gone two weeks one day 15 hours
not that I'm counting there's already
been a sharp uptick in Underworld
activities
Oh
little Grant Morrison action disappeared
I can't get away from you
the suit so the storyline they teased
James Gunn teased is actually Dick
Grayson in the bat suit I don't think
that's what they're gonna do but that is
that run that thing that's sick
I want to read that at very least oh
it's so good if you'd finally accept Mr
Wayne's offer we could do lunch every
day dad with your background in physics
and math dad you'd be an extraordinary
asset Exposition Dad
I said no before I went into the service
and it's it is Lucius have Damien and
Bruce Wayne's hairline it's in
requirement of all Wayne employees if
you reach certain levels you gotta have
the same
[Music]
like an Osborne I'm gonna get those
cornrows yeah yeah
[Music]
oh man
I thought your doctor told you whiskey
and salad yeah it's like Mama Told Me
It's Your Whiskey
are you sure he's dead Kate this is
Batman we're talking about I need your
help on this one
two boy please tell me it's not him I'll
see what my network can dig up on your
mystery man
[Applause]
she cut her hair since the first scene
it's a wig in the comics because that
noise that's one one more thing to throw
off people off the trail
watch your back Kate
ah you got this cake said a wig does
seem like it'd be kind of a liability in
a fight I mean that's falling off pull
your cow all over the place
Gotham's my [__]
[Music]
let me fix that for you
he was dead he got better
people
had a Ninja Turtle flashback for a
second there it's coming back
[Music]
I have to babysit you again
I could have handled this alone if
that's your best Batman you're not gonna
fool anyone Grayson hahaha
dude you gotta pulled double duty now
there's no way you're gonna pull this
off without my help
modest as ever I see some more Batman
than you'll ever
you've been tracking me all night first
tell me why you're running around Gotham
playing dress-up I'm guessing Nightwing
[Music]
just because I have some respect doesn't
mean I'm a part of your little cult you
really have a way with women Grayson
I mean he does seem to does except when
he's Batman yeah that was that was how
women wrecked Batman so I think he's
doing better
woman AKA Catherine Kane Katie she's
impressive but her methods make her a
danger to this city and to herself how
do you know her
I just do you're young
we're we're talking that's what the kids
say these days they're talking about
Heritage hanging out but who is he all I
know is that he's left a trail of empty
vaults and dead bodies across this city
with all due respect dad that doesn't
help much what am I paying you for Dad I
love you as much as you give me there's
some connection between Wayne
Enterprises and Batman I'd say you
supply him with some of his Tech that's
some Theory Dad I just
oh
[__] Theory confirmed get us into the
Vault Mr Fox or your son becomes
he's not a licensed chiropractor
that we know of that's true that's true
everybody had a job before the job
a Goblin glider
why not man
probably captured all sorts of strange
Tech in here aside from what they build
in-house
yeah yeah so cool
use your speeding agility boy get him
I'm really impressed with all the
animated movies have different set
pieces to like mix up the fighting yeah
they're really good at making them feel
different unique each one yeah yeah like
well choreographed interesting locations
and the fighting styles change with who
they're fighting and oh
[Music]
almost got his Dick Grayson
classic
electrocutioner stop I have a soft spot
for children who you stupid
oh
interesting that's an interesting way to
see a boss kill a Hench better than the
just like I need to prove a point real
quick
take off mother's pearls
where did you get oh oh what where did
you get that jewelry
the hell was this
it's that Ayahuasca trip you're on
hop in there Bruce it's okay oh
oh oh oh God
cool
at two dick
it's cool seeing some of the like Grant
Morrison influence uh directly
always looks like it hurts just so much
eye stuff
oh Mad Hatter mad Hatton yeah Abraham
Lincoln Abraham Hatter
descendant of Lincoln Mad Hatter
everybody knows it threading my way
through the layers you're like wet sand
compared to this concrete it's as if he
defines himself by his pain such Madness
push past the trauma wait a minute is
that Tally's back he was nearly killed
but I saved him we should capture Damien
bring him
that's brownie points I'm his new daddy
look at me show him this he will love it
weapons that my dad created and almost
got killed I understand I really do but
it's not my call things are complicated
trust me okay nah suit up let's do the
John Ridley run everybody's gotta get a
suit the back community
I wonder how big it is going to be in
that live action take on this you're a
cop
a detective you have a problem with that
no not at all
you just don't look the part I'm
something of a detective myself
not as hot as you
did I just say that out loud yeah you
did following dad's orders
I haven't dated in over a year and I
yeah can I give you my card call me yeah
right I like you but something's come up
I love you based on these 30 seconds
we've spoken like why is it why is
exchange information not enough
where's the kid
why'd you say that name
Grayson you know when we were kids and
I'd see it all the society bashes
I had quite a crush on you really I
thought you were totally annoying
[Laughter]
it's okay Master dick was quite explicit
at least 24 hours of observation he's
not my father and neither were you and
for that young man you should be
profoundly grateful
oh boy I don't see Alfred's potential
kid
when I got kicked out of the military no
shame in a little Rave sex drugs and
techno house
how you doing gorgeous out of my way
[__] I don't think so
shave that bat-shaped goatee right now
yeah scumbag
that's my favorite move sometimes you
gotta throw a body at a body
ah
oh
Christmas
oh time to suit up oh
here we go
[Music]
get your own Darth Vader montage
whoa
wow
cyber bat yeah it's Alfred your butler
is a part of this too trust me it's a
total badass
yeah watch the prequel show
who are you
I'm you Damien
huh
all grown up what
he wanted to create the perfect Soldier
they used your DNA and put it through a
process of accelerated growth
[Music]
mother
how dare you it wasn't my idea this
lunatic said he killed me if I shut up I
like his Chucks that sucks
Comfort preparedness I've always served
you without question I've never asked
anything of you
mommy how could I not have felt the
depths of your pain How could a mother
have left her child so alone in the dark
ugh wow
[Laughter]
you have no use to me like this for
calcitrant emotional your father's
influence no doubt Onyx get this trash
out of here take out the trash Tyler is
a boss
guns and Guns it's a whole sub-genre of
movie this whole sequence directed by
Robert Rodriguez none exploitation
running like just but they're nuns
they're not just
not just with gun just why are they in
the live action movies is what I want to
know James Gunn adapt this directly
James none James Nunn with the gun ninja
nuns bar son
[Music]
you're shooting nuns they're shooting
yeah what else you want come on this is
every Catholic school kids fantasy oh
mama oh
[Music]
it is a fatal flaw
sweet slow nurse
battling
that's original
Batman
there's a template there's a name
generator it's like how childish Gambino
got it you gotta plug it in you gotta
see what's log into the bat General
what's available even
relax dude Matt Ludwig gordonson last
night
racing whoa imagine him scoring a bat oh
dude dude
[Music]
and we'll just leave these highly
valuable prisoners here chilling
see you got a little circus in you oh
yeah
oh
iron bat yeah the parallels are in
Batman and Iron Man weren't strong
enough
for you guys this is what he is
smack him again you know you wanna
yep yep
yep it is
[Music]
God's Not Gonna like this I don't think
she's been here for a while
oh yeah
it has like almost any Gordo
oh
yeah come on come on
got a little Indiana Jones yes
how are you
how are you I'm Batman
that's all I had to say how are you I'm
Batman
he's Batman
[Music]
you harm one hair on her weave
yeah
gratifying thing they get to do ah just
Glide silhouetted
what do you do when it's not a full moon
though
dramatic lighting find a way yeah Street
Lamp
oh kiddo you're about about a little
there gonna pull your top half apart
[Music]
I hope Bruce fights the rest of his this
movie in his underwear sometimes you
gotta box boxers
and you know they're specially designed
bat under oh 100 logo all up in them
yeah little utility belt
toothpaste floss for nights four Dark
Knights too bad they got away dad always
wanted me to work with Bruce Wayne we
can handle this on our own
Robin such a big help I'm also that's
not true because you'd be dead you
really should be resting the summit's
tomorrow
it's been a week I'm fine I gotta fight
with Superman tonight
Bruce Wayne arrived to deliver the
keynote address that will kick off the
conference and also unveil
groundbreaking technological advances
researchers wow nice place what a home
find anything on that hard drive yet no
I gave it to Batwing
nothing to be sorry about goodbye dick
just like that no more Batwoman kicked
out of the bat family
oh damn it
now the question is has he been brain
jacked yep he looks pretty vacant tied
I'll take a 50 on calling that
[Music]
oh yeah
yeah yeah I was gonna say I had to hurt
more than a regular knife a man of peace
Mr Bruce Wayne
that's what I think of when I think of
Bruce Wayne
kindness
taking people out of the family left and
right so kind with these translators we
hope to build Bridges between language
and culture
Wayne Tech and Star Labs have developed
the Watchtower initiative
on the greatest adventure oh oh my
Batman Inc Eye in the Sky
[Music]
yeah I was gonna say you're unveiling
your flying surveillance station while
you got these guys on the loose not
great I want a mobile office is out of a
suitcase and all the leaders she would
need are at the summit of course they
are Swain
Dick's got a great hairdo it's like an
almost mullet which I respect yeah it's
got that Jared Padalecki hair yeah
oh
not Alfred you don't punch Alfred I
don't care who you are so many Minds
so little time
and a new age dog
hey babbling need a ride in me
beautiful sky good thing you got us
those schematics but my dad understands
when he finds out I hacked his computer
yeah he'll be fine
it's what he's always wanted you're in
the family business now yeah
oh
nice
that's awesome
[Music]
oh
blatant memory Bruce betray Batman we've
got to find the dignitaries and evacuate
them our first priority is getting those
people out
they've been so loyal
I know from where he's come from to here
yeah I mean he doesn't really care about
lives but still loves Bruce Bruce's life
that's a start
join us or die
philosophy never pays off
got him by the tusks
there is no you you have no hoe you have
no people there is only Zuul I mean
Alfred's just too ready at all times
he's he's gonna take care of him he's
Batman's butler all right
the glue
guns on guns gunfu
yep
let's do this let's go
[Music]
it's like you're seeing stars for a hot
second there
[Music]
I just love that they went Ham on the
sky they're about it pretty little
Crayola action most beautiful magic hour
fight you've ever seen it's a full hour
magic hour yep
yeah don't fight me on a Star Wars set
again yeah you are fighting on them
thing in the sky going into Gotham no
good and it just takes off right in the
direction of the city
the Voyages of the USS Enterprise Alfred
jeez it's like fist is the the size of
Damien yep oh
a full evolution of his Arc
Vengeance Justice not Vengeance my guy
well done
yeah
damn
you're trying got a situation yeah you
had the right idea you passed anyway
yeah
fight interrupted by building well [__]
like that Luger too she's got pretty
awful Point play game with it because
she does she does it's that German
engineering
[Music]
ah damn it
selfish yeah
and my sixth training don't pick up
penny worth come on take you out 11
times out of ten
oh
blue is mine oh
oh you've got a clock worked
bloody hell
[Music]
that's what a decapitation looks like
it's his head exploded to like all of
him explodes I couldn't quite tell but
it doesn't leave an empty suit
I did not think we'll see Mad Hatter in
another one of these no
no
a little surprised in fact it seems like
kind of a notable Village yeah no not
anymore
and Foster for Mad Hatter
oh good car right we need some Ben
faster
[Music]
God
come on Gundam bat
[Music]
oh
getting tired that dead arm
come on dick
well done beloved we will at least
victory
oh where's the programming finish him
tool the enemy
it's all about
[Music]
you've never killed
don't let her take your soul like how
it's Nightwing's weapon and her weapon
we needed family we needed you shoot him
you're not just a mask you're a man
a masked man I like how much I hate
seeing Batman in the gun that like this
they conveyed that wrongness
like it yeah oh
oh dude
for the little boy who lost his world in
that alley enough
oh that look on his face
I'm sorry
I'm okay so sorry
[Music]
that's for what you did to my father
[__]
[__] I have thought of little else for
the last 12 years not the death of my
father not even our child could bring
you to my side you left yeah you done
[__] up you're pissed out you're
brainwashed let me try to kill your kid
you did you messed up
[Music]
yeah flying trash compactor it was ready
the whole time on loan from the Ewoks
or the sand people you know sand people
yeah
hmm
tuscans Tuscan Raiders that's right no
in fact the correct answer was Jawas
oh
him fighting
and that's the last we'll see of Talia
and Onyx and killed off screen yeah
hit the water charged with nitroglycerin
I don't know what happened there but it
happened it's a tribute to The Dark
Knight Rises where he takes the news
well I suppose touch could have done it
I'm proud of you Kate
Gabrielle and Elizabeth would be proud
to just wrap your head of the concussion
so you do yeah I guess so you know just
recite your birthday and your address
and you're right on time
cute damn just skipping straight to
lunch with the parents yeah
she really did like a good drink
[Music]
I'm mad I assume you're my son
I recognize that chin he was more
saluting just to the tech
despite her Madness she was his mother
turtle legs are back very happy about it
oh the turtlenecks it's the good Sally
needs like a little change yeah
[Music]
bad blood not a vampire movie I want a
vampire Batman movie that's what I want
outro Montage bitchin cool I'm gonna
come together as a family of their
different vehicles
yeah they do yes
quarter mile at a time there they go
that's right that's right race for pig
slips
[Music]
it's like Nightwing's a tuner guy
Batman's an American muscle guy sure
yeah 100 yeah
Gotham SS or something like that or like
an old Camaro yeah
[Music]
all right the five of us let's go get
the penguin in a car
that's right this isn't excessive this
is not Overkill there's not other crime
we could divide and conquer more
efficiently
it's good big family
ah cool I like the ending so this is the
official moment that taught me then that
if you see the black with the red it's
Kate Kate if you see purple with the
yellow it's Babs woman girl woman also
jmd uh de matteus wrote this as well
comic writer like last time that's
exciting ah nice all right hell yeah
he's a guy that wrote a lot of like uh
Ben Reilly Spider-Man stuff he was a
Marvel guy back in the 90s
Ben Reilly
uh Scarlet Spider the clone of
Spider-Man one of my favorite characters
of all time oh dude I got a I'm a clone
saga Defender I'm one of the few I got
us I gotta check it out I gotta see if I
agree I uh people hate the clone saga
but I think Ivan straw
hofsky was that woman interested we're
gonna back her in his back yeah John
DiMaggio a little bit a little bit okay
Travis Willingham hell yeah it's a good
voice cast yeah it was solid I gotta
peep I want to make sure is there a post
credit guys I'm trying to drink a gallon
a day it's not easy
so okay you're doing so great I just you
know it's a full full movie future links
I just don't want to spin the reviews
spinning in my chair prancing no I don't
believe there is sweet freedom
all right all righty oh so that is
probably like the most connected uh one
we've had bat specific but also maybe
the most connected we're gonna have to
what James Gunn's doing sure okay
because uh Grant Morrison run is uh
kicks off with Nightwing in the Batman
tool okay so there's a lot of
correlation there which would be
interesting to see if Italian uh where
is Bruce and all of this I mean he is
presumed dead in in the book so uh I
don't know if they'd want like just
because they showed the cover of that
comic doesn't mean like it wasn't like
the super girl announcement where they
were like we're doing this like this
yeah it's this run it's more it's like
it's inspired by this take but I don't
know if you'd want to start a Batman
without Batman but it'd be kind of fun
to be like like if the people know
Batman enough the hunt for Batman could
be fun yeah like the mystery of Batman
yeah and I think that would be create a
new way to build excitement towards the
new Batman in a different way that's not
just about people who paid attention to
movie news waiting for a cast again yes
you know yes and also like introducing
the bat family as like a family already
established would be interesting to do
yeah like they did here because I think
we are at a point now where you know the
culture knows Batman well enough that I
think you can start to screw around with
who's in the cowl and right and the
different Associates who are going to
pop up frequently and it would give
Nightwing some time in the sun which
everyone wants I feel like that Wing's
been like way overdue I was gonna say
aren't they is that Nightwing movie they
were trying to do is that the Christmas
there's a Christmas cake yeah I mean
that's been in development for like 10
years okay so I don't know so that's in
limbo and will likely be repurposed as
as they kick off the new DC and maybe
they'll use some of it like maybe
they'll then you know do a Nightwing
with it okay but we'll see
um I liked it didn't love it yeah to me
this was one of the ones where uh it's
kind of in the middle like it's solid I
had a lot of fun it felt more like an
episode of a show than yeah most of the
other movies have I agree with that felt
more like you know just kind of one in
many ongoing Adventures maybe like a
special episode because you think Bruce
is gone but yeah it kind of moved and
and felt like something out of a series
yeah it was nice to be cohesive uh like
it was nice to feel that Damien
connection it's nice to see him evolve
and grow all those things were good
um but I definitely like found myself
not distracted but like not as intensely
riveted not as gripped yeah and I don't
know why like there's no real direct
reason but like it was good I'd give it
like a b whereas I just think that
Turtles was like such an a it's well
yeah because that one just fires on all
the things you want for fun but then it
goes harder on the things that they
don't have to focus as heavily on like
they made that an actual movie and they
bothered to like really fast yeah that's
right the tones together and the worlds
together and they really kind of smartly
created that Harmony whereas whereas
here you know uh this was I feel like a
little slight on certain detail that was
like the whole thing with um what do we
call him again you know the big clone
bat heretic there you go uh like that's
a really cool looking character really
cool concept of a character and I feel
like once we got the reveal of heretic
it was kind of like and he's done
bye-bye it felt more like he just
existed ultimately to feel these clones
yeah for the Betrayal and to reveal that
she's got you know Damien's genetic
material on hand to just like keep
perfecting the perfect Soldier or
whatever but I felt like there could
have been like an emotional punch to
that rather than just like oh man this
is this big bad who somehow managed to
yeah to take Batman hostage and he's got
his image and and it just seemed like
there was so much there's a lot more
Nuance that could have been used with
that yeah it's like the appearance
suggests it it's like oh man this is
really pointed this is clearly I I
thought it was gonna have something to
do with them trying to tarnish the
Batman's reputation because this guy
does so much resemble him but in more of
a gladiatorial kind of way and then yell
the whole you know cloning and this even
the mirroring of like bat family to the
likeness of you they didn't really lean
into like the fact that in the movie
that introduces him he's forming a
family and like the Betrayal of self and
like the lack of like you know Batman
holding a gun is him fighting against
all his instincts and then like you know
that villain kind of represents the way
Jamie and lost fighting those instincts
like they could have paralleled those
things you know there was just a couple
opportunities that would have been nice
to go deeper yeah absolutely and and two
I feel like um that is a great shot
though when he's got oh man it's so
intense and the stick and like you know
there's a lot like Alfred's always great
Nightwing is always great I even I like
their Damien a lot here I know people go
back and forth on Damien I think he
works here yeah uh Bruce the thing is
too it's like having Bruce be out of
commission and kidnapped like I liked I
thought the best stuff was the focus
they gave to
Kate and Dick and and Damien and Alfred
all that stuff was pretty good and then
the rest of it also felt like what am I
trying to say it seemed like having
Bruce taken out of commission and put
through this like mental rigor of them
like searching his mind and and stuff
like I thought that also could have been
a little just more Hefty that one scene
was great I would love to see more of
that yeah because like that's a struggle
like I feel like we didn't we get the
moment at the end where he has the
struggle you know with the weapons and
everything and that is cathartic but I
thought
I don't know like maybe show us some of
that talk he has with Damien you know
more so or or more of it you know we get
a little bit of it but but yeah like
something about this it
for how episodic it kind of feels this
one yeah it seems weird to have such a
tumultuous circumstance as Batman being
decommissioned and kidnapped and you
know experimented upon so I in a weird
way it felt like there wasn't as much
like of that heft or that kind of like
dark when they go for these things a lot
of the time it's called Bad Blood and
like that's you know dealing with you
know Damien being cloned as dealing with
like their history it's dealing with all
those things but that was all the stuff
they like kind of breezed out not
breezed over but they could have dove
into the title earned yeah especially
for one of the slider movies too in
terms of yeah I mean run time very short
I mean Talia like I did kind of feel
like thinking back on the continuity
It's Like Son of Batman she takes off
like there is I believe a little
conversation at the end about you know
perhaps kind of both being involved with
Damien yeah there was almost like a
neutrality and that was the last time we
saw her and then she was also like there
was a love for Damien that wasn't a
parent here yeah and then she's like ah
you know like because you all made it
impossible I'm not like no you just you
got on your boats we all agree we were
sharing custody we were sharing custody
now you come back with clones and you
think I'm the problem yeah it's like you
chose this and when did this happen he
was gone for like a year yeah he was
still monkeys like he was like she she
said 12 years ago I think we met him
when he was 10. so two years at most
have gone by sure that is accelerated
clothing yes yeah so like things like
that are are you know it adds up but
still an enjoyable time still a b still
funny still fun still well choreographed
still action-packed entertaining still a
great adaptation
um but you know there's some that are
just exceptional and this was good yeah
yeah I'll put this in the decent yeah
yeah not bad time a lot of fun badass
moments and stuff a lot of fun Rogues it
was nice to see like Firefly on screen
and stuff like that yeah I love Mad
Hatter again Ben Foster Castle uh but
yeah I'm really curious how they adapt
this live action if this is the story
they choose to tell uh really curious
about you know the the next step in the
bat family after this because Damian is
you know Justice not Vengeance like it's
really cool to see that
um I love the direct commentary I
remember one of the things I was
bothered by with Justice League War was
the the the characterization of Wonder
Woman and Superman but I do love this
characterization of Batman this is in
that same universe so it's nice to see a
Batman that is staunchly no guns to the
point of it being a plot point I'm
enjoying those elements so um and that
doesn't feel any less gritty and and
like you know yeah the whole no guns
thing doesn't hamper any of the bones
it's not a weapon he would use it's the
weapon of the coward yeah and the way he
uses it finally I was like cool yeah
uses it to deflect a different weapon
nice like you know and it doesn't feel
like anything is lost by putting
emphasis on that yeah I agree yeah so
good not great uh but very much enjoy
this is a B for me personally quick
question batwing yep what how how rich
is the history across so I've actually
got a tricky thing with batwing because
to me bat wing is one of those like
power set characters where it's like
well then like if you're Iron Man that
undermines all the bat like as soon as
you introduce Tech but he's good at math
they've said it I could but like so as
soon as you introduce him it's like why
is he chasing penguin like it it really
affects the whole as soon as Iron Man's
fighting alongside Nightwing and Batman
and all that stuff it makes them all
very you know it seems like batwing
should be in Space the power structure
really shifts
um so he's got a history I just it's
never a character I've really enjoyed my
bat family that I enjoy are all street
level like I like when it's you know the
characters that have to stay on the
ground because because then that's the
charm of Batman joining with the Justice
League right because that's that's that
heart so like he's got history it's just
not I mean to me Batman Beyond is the
only time I like Batman in Tech because
it's in the future and that's what he
has to do to keep up so you know Batman
Bruce Wayne designs a suit to keep up
with the modern day criminals because
he's getting older Terry McGinnis you
know needs that to keep up so like if
you've gotta attack Batman in the modern
day it doesn't really seem you've got
like half Batman half cyborg or
something like yeah it's just not a
character I personally like it's a
little overpower he also learned how to
[__] do that soon like 30 minutes you
just put it on it's like good thing I
got these skills Lucius made a very easy
to follow instructional video he just
did a lot of video game automatics where
he's like and this is how you do this
this way press X and Y to fire batarang
so it's not a character I've read a lot
but he pops up a decent amount um and
there's tons of bad family there's even
more than that but I'm always more on
the side of uh you know Batgirl Batwoman
Nightwing Robin yeah that's my world
that makes sense uh except to see what's
next we don't know
I mean it's always a mystery we don't
even know if
I mean that was a moment and there is
some really beautiful animation across
like and especially when they do those
establishing shots of like the monastery
and things like the longest Convent I
should say yeah the lock is golden hour
in history but that was the power of the
nunnery yeah more Nuns with guns I mean
nudges should be just James Gunn how
it's time how has there not been a
character who's a nun who exclusively
uses nunchucks oh call it none chaku
the movie are there any actors Chuck
Norris is very old but are there any
actors named Chuck that could team up
with a nun and then you've got
non-shocks anyone named Charles besides
Xavier there's got to be an actor named
Charles Martin That's the voice of Mario
Charles
this is good writes itself it writes
you're welcome Hollywood you know after
cocaine bear nunchucks Universal we're
available to write nunchuck oh I'm on
the script already who do we got we got
uh uh Rosario Dawson oh Charlie Day
definitely not a truck nunchuck Rosary I
want to see it yeah we'll then see the
opportunity becomes you know you can
cast like some heavyweighters like
Mother Superior like like Salma Hayek or
somebody or who's a who's uh like Carla
Gugino Carla Gugino is the ultimate nun
yeah Rosario she could kick an ass and
then Rosario Dawson's like the main one
jump you into the world Charlie day is
just overwhelmed and squeaky and excited
but he's Chuck yeah none shot
guys we're here all week we're here
every day
we'll be back next week with uh the
nunchucks equal again we don't know what
it is yet but let us know in the
comments what you enjoyed the most of
this watch what you'd like us to watch
next what of these where do you rank
this in your scale and we are thinking
at the end of this Grand Journey 40 in
50 and who knows how many movies in
we're gonna rank them John on uncoi's
comic corner and we're gonna make a list
and we'll have a list of we'll have like
a like a final four I'm excited to see
if there are any ones we will I want to
get in into a tussle over at least one
yeah it's gonna be weird
[Music]
yeah and even even from our different
degrees of like comic knowledge which I
feel like we're still able to kind of
meet in the middle so contestants how
good they are yeah like you know my
having read the Social Security and you
haven't but you having knowledge of the
characters that shows how adaptable
absolutely well that is a good place to
end at your lovelies thank you for
watching we'll see you soon like
subscribe all those things comments
YouTube it all and stay hydrated so you
have to Pete right at the very end
you'll see that in the edit all right
bye guys
uh you haven't seen this no I've never
seen any of these coins every time it's
good it's good you gotta keep me on
because I'm saying it's the first time
to you this is the first one we're gonna
get 20 into this you're like no I've
seen this one I'd be like John this is
suddenly all familiar this is weird I've
seen Batman versus Turtles 72. but I
haven't seen the rest of them I haven't
seen that hasn't seen them
[Music]